ils sont réunis pour défendre le
programme et le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron deux figures politiques
emblématiques côte à côte un ministre de
droite en poste jean-baptiste lemoyne et
un ex ministre ancien numéro deux du
parti socialiste françois rebsamen qui
votera macron j'appelle à voter emmanuel
macron clairement mais je ne suis pas en
marche je ne suis pas un territoire de
progrès et j'aspire à recréer avec
d'autres une force de gauche de
gouvernement après l'élection
présidentielle et donc je ne me priverai
pas de dire ce que j'ai à dire le moment
venu tous les deux on vient d'horizons
politiques différents lui
social-démocrate moi issu de la droite à
l'époque de l'ump mais nous nous
retrouvons derrière le projet du
président le cap qu'il trace pour la
france 130 personnes étaient présentes
dans la salle parmi lesquels des figures
locales de la république en marche comme
rémy rebeyrotte et denis thuriau à
l'image des grands débats le meeting se
déroule par un jeu de questions et
réponses
à chacun ses arguments pour défendre le
bilan des manuels macron le ministre en
fonction site les mesures phares du
quinquennat
le maire de dijon et ancien ministre du
travail lui veut mettre en avant les
avancées sociales du candidat président
et si françois rebsamen et présents à ce
meeting c'est pour renforcer l'idée du
rassemblement voulue par l'actuel
locataire de l'elysée
maintenant que son message passe un
petit peu sur les halles à la fois sur
la droite il entendu le centre-droit
dont je faisais partie et aussi sur la
gauche où les idées sont bonnes aussi
complètement indécise puisque là j'étais
là en tant que curieuse et en cherchant
des réponses à nos questions tant que
chef d'entreprise de services à domicile
pour le moment voilà le programme est
vaste les réponses sont vastes donc on
attend de voir ça montre que même des
gens qui ont pas toujours les mêmes
idées de son peut s'entendre pour
vraiment construire quelque chose de
plus efficace à 12 semaines du premier
tour les marcheurs et leurs alliés
affichent leur ferme intention de faire
réélire emmanuel macron